الاهتمام بالاستثمار في قطاع الالعاب بات
امرا واقعا وهو ظاهره الزاد والسعوديه
مثال على ذلك وهي اصبحت للتوها اكبر مساهم
خارجي في شركه نينتندو صندوق الاستثمارات
العامه فحصته في هذه الشركه اليابانيه من
6 الى اكثر من ثمانيه في المئه وهي زياده
الثالثه الصندوق السيادي في هذه الشركه
هذا الاستثمار يعني ان حصه السعوديه
تجاوزت حصه صندوق استثمار المعاشات
التقاعديه الياباني واصبح ثانيا وراء
نفسها اي المالك الرئيسي الاساسي خلال
الاسبوع الماضي ايضا دخلت مجموعه للالعاب
التابعه للصندوق الاستثمارات العامه قطاع
الالعاب الصيني لاول مره وذلك من خلال
شركه في اس بي او باستثمارات تقدر ب 265
مليون دولار تحلل المزيد حول حجم سوق
الالعاب الالكترونيه ما على سرحان
تتصدر العاب الهاتف حجم الايرادات السنويه
في سوق الالعاب العالمي في عام 2022 حققت
ما يقرب من 92 مليار دولار اي نحو 50% من
ايرادات السوق ولعبه اونوروس الصينيه جاءت
على راس القائمه بمليارين و200 مليون
دولار اما العاب وحدات العاب الفيديو مثل
البلاي ستيشن
فقدرت ايراداتها العالميه ب51 مليار دولار
و800 مليون دولار في السعوديه تهدف سافي
جروب لانشاء 250 شركه العاب داخل المملكه
وتوفير 39 الف فرصه عمل كما تخطط
الاستثمار 37 مليار و800 مليون دولار في
صناعه الالعاب خلال السنوات المقبله يملك
صندوق الاستثمارات السعوديه اسهم في كوبرا
شركات الالعاب من ضمنها دولار وتسعمائه
مليون دولار في شركه
المنتجه
ومليار و900 مليون دولار في المنتجه
لالعاب فيفا تهدف استراتيجيه السعوديه
ايضا الى انتاج اكثر من 30 لعبه في
استوديوهات محليه قادره على المنافسه
العالميه وان يسهم القطاع بنحو 13 مليار
وثلاثمائه مليون دولار من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي بحلول عام 2030
واذا اردنا ان نعطي للمشاهدين معلومات
مفيده عن تندو الشركه المسؤوله عن سوبر
ماريو بوكيمون الشهيرين هي لم تبدا كشركه
العاب فيديو بالاساس هي كانت بطاقات لعبه
اسست في سبتمبر عام 1899 استمر الوضع كذلك
كندير لعقود لكن في عام 1959 عقدت نينتندو
صفقت مع صفقه اوراق لاعب مطبوق عليها
شخصيات ديزني حققت نجاحا وقتها ساحقا ساعد
الشركه على ادراج اسهمها في البورصه لاول
مره
والسبعينات من القرن قبل الماضي كانت لحظه
فاصله في تاريخ هذه الشركه فاصدرت اول
لعبه الكترونيه في اليابان
ولم تكن لعبه فيديو لعبه اطفال هي عباره
عن مسدس مضيء وبيعت منه انا ذاك اكثر من
مليون وحده وفي عام 1975 دخلت علم تصميم
العاب الفيديو ولم تحقق نجاحا كبيرا الا
عام 81 عندما اطلقت لعبه دونكي كونج الذي
ظهرت فيها شخصيات ماريو بشكل بدائي قبل ان
تنتج اول لعبه باسم ماريو عام 83 طيب
اليوم اذا احنا بدنا نسال نفسنا وين صارت
نينتندو الى اين هذه الشركه تبلغ قيمتها
السوقيه حاليا اكثر من 52 مليار دولار منذ
اطلاق اخر مشغل لالعابها نينتندو سويتش في
باعت الشركه نحو 122 مليون وحده لتصبح
ثالث اكبر مشغل العاب مبيعا في التاريخ